What if you could remember everything?
>> [music]
>> Every conversation, every meal, every
detail of every day you've ever lived. I
would say
>> [music]
>> that sounds incredible because in
reality, I forget names, I forget where
I put my keys, [music] I have forgotten
entire years of my childhood. Each time
I forget something these days, [music] I
treat it like a failure, like my brain
has let me down. And yes, I start to
worry that I have dementia. In this
video, I want to take you inside the
science [music]
of forgetting because forgetting might
be one of the most important things your
brain does.
Let me explain. At University College
Dublin, psychologist Ciara Greene
studies how memories are formed. She and
her colleague Jillian Murphy wrote a
book about this topic. One striking
[music] story Ciara told me was about a
woman with an extremely rare condition.
She can recall virtually every event in
her life.
>> [music]
>> So, Jill Price is a woman who's know
very well known because she has an
extremely rare condition that's called
highly superior autobiographical memory.
Somebody who you might be able to say,
"Tell me what the weather was like on
the 30th of September 1998."
>> [music]
>> Um and most of us would go, "How on
earth would I possibly know that?" Um
but somebody with HSAM, someone like
Jill, would say, "Oh, yeah, I remember.
Um it was really sunny, um but the
clouds came over at about 3:00. We
thought for a while it was going to
rain, but then it didn't." And you know,
would be able to give you this extremely
detailed blow-by-blow account of their
own personal
experiences. Sounds like a superpower,
right?
But not all of Jill's memories are about
idyllic afternoons where she hangs out
with her friends.
Some of her memories
are less happy.
Take one memory from the time she was a
little kid. Jill's father worked as the
agent for Jim Henson, the creator of the
Muppets. One time, he arranged for
Jill's entire nursery school class to
visit the studio where the puppets were
made.
The kids looked forward to the outing
for weeks.
But when the day rolled around, Jill had
tonsillitis. She couldn't go.
Her dad, of course, had committed to
taking the whole class to the studio.
The studio was expecting to see a bunch
of excited kids.
He couldn't just drop the plan because
Jill was sick.
So, he decided to go ahead
without her.
To little Jill, this was devastating.
Her own daddy was going to leave her
behind and take all of her friends to
see the [music] Muppets. And even though
she had tonsillitis, so she had a really
sore throat, she still you know, like at
their like screaming at the at the top
of her lungs, screaming at her parents
that they were not letting them go. Now,
you've probably had a meltdown like this
as a kid. But here's the thing.
You don't remember the meltdown. You
don't remember how you felt as you
[music] melted down. Jill
does.
For her, it's like it never stopped
happening.
>> [music]
>> And she says, you know, whenever time
she she thinks about it, um she still
feels this this overwhelming sense of of
of disappointment every time she sees
the Muppets. So, every time you see a
Muppets Christmas Carol, you're brought
back to this moment. Really like almost
being right back there again and feeling
it
as though she's right there in the
moment. I have a memory of my own from
childhood. I was 11 or 12 running around
in an outdoor parking lot. It was dark
[music] out. The parking lot wasn't
paved and the surface was uneven. There
may have been tree roots sticking out of
the ground [music] here and there.
I tripped, fell hard,
and landed on my ring finger.
It was incredibly painful. [music] I
remember crying.
But today,
I cannot actually feel the pain anymore.
I'm not even sure if it was the ring
finger on my right hand or my left hand.
This is what we mean when we say [music]
that time heals our wounds. What we're
really saying is that time helps us to
forget. But not for someone like Jill.
Now, this is where the story turns
really dark. Jill fell deeply in love
with a man named Jim. They were married.
It It a wonderful relationship.
But after only two years of marriage,
Jim suffered a stroke.
He was 42 years old and he died.
And so she describes in really great
detail how um when she you know her
father came home and told her that Jim
had collapsed at work and then they're
driving to the hospital and she goes
through in this just exhaustive detail
every phone call she made to the nurse
and then the nurse is telling her this
and then you know all these details of
the drive to the hospital.
And then how you know what the doctors
were you know this this horrible
situation where he was in critical care
for days and then eventually the doctors
had to tell her that they had to turn
off the life support machines. Now, no
normal person will forget that their
beloved spouse has died. But for most
people, the details will get blurry over
time.
Not for Jill. And she says that even
like every time now years and years
later, she can't drive down that road
where she where they drove to the
hospital because every vivid little
detail of that drive to the hospital is
is there as comes comes back and they
don't fade with time.
So,
tell me now,
do you want to have a perfect memory?
To recall everything that happened to
you every single day of your life? Can
you start to see how our capacity to
forget is actually something of a
superpower? Let's spend a minute
understanding why we remember some
things and forget others.
The first thing to understand is that
most of us make a huge mistake when we
think about how our memories work. We
have an image of a filing cabinet inside
our heads. We pull open a drawer, drop
in a folder, and the folder sits there
waiting for us to retrieve it whenever
we want. Or we see something and it's
like taking a photograph.
>> [music]
>> We drop the photograph into a folder
that sits on a computer hard disk inside
our heads. That's not how our memories
work.
Rather than thinking of memory as being
at this kind of passive process where we
just file information away and then it
just stays there, memory is actually
this really active process. It's a bit
of a mind-bending idea, but lots of
scientific research shows that it's
true.
Our memories are not recollections as
much as they are reconstructions. When
we remember something, we play an active
role in what we remember. We're not just
pulling something out of a filing
cabinet. Our moods, the situations and
contexts in which we find ourselves,
they shape what we remember. When you
think about it for a moment, you can see
why it would be completely impractical
for the brain to remember everything
that happens to us.
Like think about what you had for
breakfast today. You could, if you think
of that computer metaphor, you could
imagine that for every single day of
your life, you should have a perfect
recollection of exactly how what you ate
for breakfast, how you poured out the
cornflakes, how you poured out the milk,
how you sat down at the table, picked up
your spoon, how many bites you ate, how
many times you chewed each bite. But
honestly, what a waste of time to
remember all of these things in such
detail. Really, all you really need to
know is to sort of condense all of that
information into
"Usually, I eat cornflakes for
breakfast." Most of the time,
remembering all of these very repetitive
events in our lives in this perfect
individual detail is actually a really
inefficient way of storing information.
>> [music]
>> One of the amazing things our minds do
is to throw away most of the details of
our experiences and retain only the
gist. You generally know you eat
breakfast, you like cereal, you don't
like eggs.
What you ate for breakfast on March
18th, [music] 2024?
Completely unimportant. That's why you
remember driving to a friend's house,
but don't remember every traffic light
or every turn you took. Your brain
retains the gist
and discards the rest.
Kira says, "This is why it's a mistake
to think that being able to remember
something is good
and forgetting something is bad."
Forgetting is actually a fundamental
component of memory. We tend to think of
of getting almost as as the flip side of
memory, and that memory is a positive,
what we're supposed to do, and then
forgetting is the the thing that the
accidental thing that happens. But
that's really not the case. Like
forgetting is a fundamental element of
what happens in our in our memory
[clears throat] processes. One reason
it's easier to remember some things is
because there are multiple pathways in
the brain that lead to that memory.
Think of it like a city grid. There are
places in the city that have lots of
roads and highways connected to them.
And there are places that are out of the
way that have only a single alley
leading up to them.
The places that have lots of roads
leading to them are easier to get to.
Your memory is like that, too. If you
think about in you know how memories are
formed in the brain, um they're formed
by synapses forming connections between
different neurons. And some of those
networks have lots and lots of
connections to them. So there's like
lots and lots of roads or routes to that
particular memory. Lots of paths by
which we can access it. Um but some of
our memories are kind of those networks
are a little less dense and there are
fewer connections to them. So we don't
have as many kind of easy routes to
them. So they're they're kind of less
easily accessed in a lot of ways.
This is why sometimes seemingly random
experiences can trigger memories.
For me, I associate the smell of a
certain dish with an aunt who liked to
cook that dish when I was a kid. If the
memory of my aunt is my destination, I
can reach that destination easily when I
encounter that smell.
Um and that's kind of that that feeling
that sometimes we have where, you know,
you're you're walking down a street and
then something it could be a smell or a
sight or just something really small
triggers a memory that you haven't
thought of for years and years and
years. And that is be you know, it was
some memory some kind of something that
was um stored in such a way that it had
relatively few connections um to other
parts of your memory. And then but then
something you essentially accidentally
found yourself on the road to that
memory and and you're you're retrieving
it. Our emotions help to cement
memories, which is why we remember
things that are very emotional. Some
years ago, Ciara was riding her bike
through Dublin on a rainy November
night. It was a busy road with a lot of
buses and cars.
There was no bicycle lane. The roads
were wet.
Kira was going a little fast because she
was late. I skidded on the bike and I
skidded right in front of a bus, which
fortunately didn't hit me.
Um but it was a one of those e-bikes, an
electric bike that has, you know, the
electric power in it, which means it's
very heavy and the down tube is really
heavy. Um so as I fell, my leg got
caught in the down tube and snapped my
leg in half. It's like if you could
imagine a little small bunch of twigs
and then you snap those twigs, they
don't snap cleanly.
They snap with shards.
The bus driver called emergency
services, but the ambulance took nearly
an hour to arrive, snarled in traffic on
that wet, busy night.
Kira lay there, minute after agonizing
minute, in excruciating pain.
She told me it was the kind of pain she
had never imagined was possible. I've
never had the experience before where I
would actually scream with pain, but not
intend to.
It was completely involuntary. I'd feel
like screams were being drawn out of me
against my will. Just incredibly
ag- agonizing, like electrifyingly
sharp, overwhelming, blinding pain.
You know in a hospital where they ask
you, you know, like how's the pain on a
scale of 1 to 10? My previous 10 was now
a six on the broken leg scale of 1 to
10.
Seven months after the accident, Kira
got back on her bike to go to her
parents' house.
But something had changed. My heart was
going
like I just going like the clappers the
whole time. Um and I found that I
couldn't release my I had this death
grip on the handlebars and I couldn't
release my hands from the handlebars
enough to turn right. Uh so I could of
course we we drive in in Ireland on the
left-hand side of the road, so turning
left is is easy enough. You just stay on
the side you are. Turning right involves
crossing over the road. You have to
indicate. So I did it to prove to myself
that I could do it, but it was such an
anxiety-provoking experience that I I I
couldn't I feel there is a thing with
with a lot of activities like cycling
where you need to have a sort of
illusion of invulnerability in order to
do it. And that illusion was completely
shattered. That I knew how vulnerable I
was.
Um and there was no getting around that.
There was no pretending that this was a
safe thing to do. I no longer believed
that it was in any way a safe thing to
do. Some people have debilitating
memories about injuries. It makes
perfect sense, doesn't it? Kira got back
on her bike and her brain said,
"Remember what happened the last time
you got on a bike? Remember how painful
it was? You don't want that to happen
again, do you?" As we move through our
lives, our memories are trying to
provide us with information that is
helpful.
Notice, [music] I didn't say that our
memories are trying to provide us with
information
that is truthful. Researchers once ran a
fun study that asked people to think
back [music] to their school days. In
fact, you can try this yourself. Do you
remember tests where you got an
excellent grade? What about tests where
you did really badly? In this study,
researchers had access to all the grades
that volunteers actually got in school.
They found that when people were asked
to remember tests on which they got an A
and tests [music]
on which they got a D,
people remember their A grades
accurately 89% of the time. [music]
Their D grades, they remember those
only 29% of the time. Now, the
volunteers knew that the researchers had
access to their real grades. So, it
wasn't like they were trying to hoodwink
the researchers. Their memories had
[music] been genuinely reshaped.
Weakened when it came to failure and
strengthened when [music] it came to
success. It's kind of slightly tied into
that idea that everybody is a better
than average driver. Nobody is thinking
of themselves as being a terrible
driver, you know? Nobody is thinking
themselves as, you know, oh, I was
really only ever just average. Your
brain isn't lying to you.
It's editing for you. Keeping a version
of the past that helps you move forward.
And it goes further than grades.
>> [music]
>> In another study, researchers gave
volunteers a description of a person, a
[music] mix of positive and negative
traits.
Someone who was kind, but sometimes
[music] a bit dishonest. A mixed bag,
like all of us. Then the volunteers were
told either
this description is about you, as in
other people describe you this way,
or
this description is about someone named
Chris. And what they found is that when
people were called the Chris study, they
recalled kind of both the positive and
the negative details. But if the the
description was supposed to apply to
themselves, then they only really
recalled the positive details and they
were much less likely to recall the
negative ones. When it was about Chris,
people remembered everything, good and
[music] bad.
When it was about them,
the unflattering parts were quietly
forgotten. Their brains edited the
portrait to be a little more generous,
a little more forgiving.
Now look, I'm not going to tell you that
lying to yourself is a good thing. But
if you want to understand how memory
works, we need to ask what memory is
for. You have eyes so that you can see.
You have taste buds to taste.
Why do you have memory? Memory isn't
something that was just kind of created
out of whole cloth. It's something that
we evolved. Um and we evolved all all
the the kind of both the physical and
the mental attributes that we evolved
are things that have survived evolution
because they offer us some kind of
benefit for either survival or for
reproduction. The errors we make are
shaped by this evolutionary history. The
capacity to forget is not evidence that
your brain is faulty. It's a survival
tool.
In the ups and downs of your life,
remembering your virtues and forgetting
your flaws, remembering your successes
and forgetting your failures,
these nudge you toward happiness. So we
know that people who are happier live
longer. Um and they're healthier, you
know, all of these things. So it's not
just a kind of touchy-feely, oh I'll
feel better. It's like these things
actually have survival benefits. It's
striking that people with depression
often paint a more accurate picture of
their lives. They don't just remember
the A's.
They remember the D's. Their memories
are more truthful, but they might not be
as helpful. Kira says it's also the case
that we tend to remember things that are
similar to our present emotional states.
So, if I'm currently feeling very happy,
I'm more likely to be able to remember
events when I was happy. If I'm feeling
sad or depressed, I'm more likely to be
able to retrieve memories from my life
that are sad or depressing. And then
what that will mean is that I'll have a
kind of slightly skewed perspective of
my life, that I'll tend to, you know,
view my life as being glass half empty
instead of glass half full. This can
create a vicious cycle. So, somebody
with depression might have more
difficulty retrieving positive memories
and will find that they keep drifting
into thinking about the more negative
side. And then
because they'll do that, then we'll have
another cognitive bias that will say,
you know, "Okay, if I, you know,
retrieve, let's [music] say, six
memories from my life and four of the
memories that I retrieve are really sad
ones, I must have had a really sad
life." And that may well be true, but it
can also be influenced by the fact that
bias is leading you to retrieve those
memories in the first place and then
leading you to kind of over-interpret
the frequency of those as it as being
representative of of your life as a
whole. I'm not suggesting, of course,
that all forms of forgetfulness are
normal. People can and do develop
dementia. And if you worry that you're
losing your memory, you should talk to a
doctor about it.
But the general view that we have that
remembering things is always good and
forgetting things is always bad,
I hope I've convinced you that that view
is simply wrong.
In Chinese mythology, Meng Po is the
goddess of oblivion.
She brews a soup of five ingredients
that erases all your memories of your
life, so your soul can go on to be
reincarnated without carrying the burden
of a previous life.
Yes, [music] it's mythology.
But science is now confirming sometimes
the kindest thing a mind can do
is forget.
Thank you for watching this video. If
you want to learn more about the science
of the mind [music] and discover
practical ideas that can help you lead a
better life, check out the audio version
of the Hidden Brain podcast. Just search
for Hidden Brain on Spotify or Apple or
visit us at hiddenbrain.org.
I'm Shankar Vedantam.
See you soon.